et
regardez bien ces jeunes là ils ne sont
pas comme les autres l'espi nos cinq
jeunes du genre filaire athlétique de
l'ouest en eux
ils ne savent pas marcher tout
simplement sur le trottoir comme le
commun des mortels non ils ne regardent
pas non plus les rues comme humiliant
pour eux la moindre petite barrière le
plus commun des murs l'escalier le plus
banal et la rampe la plus insignifiante
deviennent support de sault gaffe ou
autres figures de style propre parcours
alors le parcours sa vie en fait de
parcours du combattant donc c'était en
fait des exercices mise en place de la
rva par l'armée pour entraîner soldats
approchaient les obstacles et en fait ça
a été sorti de ce contexte militaire
pour être lui
les services de la ville en fête et
c'est devenu la véritable sport le but
donc c'est donc de faire des logements
pour utiliser au maximum les
possibilités offertes par la palangrotte
mouvement international mais il ya une
dizaine d'années cet art du déplacement
est à la fois un sport est une méthode
d'entraînement qui exige techniques
maîtrise de son corps et de son esprit
a priori ça vient de france donc c'est
un certain david bell qui a mis en place
sa le parcours donc à evry à côté de
paris et voilà c'est venu jusqu'à la
réunion
les figures il en avant tout mais
rarement l'art du mouvement c'est
d'abord reproduire les techniques des
mentors tout à les agrémenter ici on est
sur un site souvent on fait beaucoup de
passe muraille d'aucuns passe muraille
en fait c'est la montée d'un mur le plus
rapidement possible en fait on on marche
sur le mur c'est le graff est ici on
fait aussi pas mal de salto donc un
salto qui s'appelle le wall fric donc en
fait c'est mon poste de pied sur le mur
et après on part en salto arrière donc
il ya plusieurs sortes de walf lippi à
l'ol flip à un pâle ou elle flippe à
deux pas où elle flippe aussi pas
simultanée c'est à dire qu'on est deux
fois le même pas sur le mur bon et ainsi
de suite la laverie et c'est
un sport encore confidentiel en matière
de plus en plus d'adeptes sur notre île
surtout n'essayez pas de faire comme eux
rien n'est improvisé tout a été préparé
ac c'est l'un des meilleurs disney
affiche déjà six ans de pratique et
d'entraînement place aux images une
artiste
donc par exemple la mouche que j'ai dit
les pas simultanée ça ça a été
personnalisé par un pratiquant de
parcours qui à la base est vue
simplement un seul flic tout simple on
est en a pas sur le muret faisant saleté
c'est vrai qu'au début on ne savait pas
vraiment que ça s'appelait du parcours
on savait pas qu'il y avait un véritable
mouvement autour de ça on a juste
commencé comme ça c'était un peu partout
escalader grimpé à avancer en fait et au
fur et à mesure on a appris qu'elle est
vraiment vraiment un mouvement qui
existe est là dessus donc on a commencé
à se renseigner à regarder des vidéos et
à vraiment s'intéresser de plus en plus
à ça et à persévérer vraiment dans la
pratique du parcours
autres disciplines du parcours la prison
de roanne peut-être escalader des
immeubles pour accéder au toit en
évitant bien sûr la cage d'escalier
beaucoup moins solidaire tout cas ça
nous est jamais arrivé d'avoir vraiment
un conflit physique avec les gens en
général ils sont surpris parce que c'est
vrai qu'à la réunion s'est pas trop
connus comme pratique mais une fois
qu'on s'explique avec eux généralement
il ya aucun souci comprennent après on
essaye de ne pas faire chez les gens
donc sur il sort trois pulls et même si
ça peut nous arriver quand même mais
voilà on s'explique et généralement tout
va bien aucun problème
alors pour moi le parcours c'est
vraiment un sport parce que tout
simplement ce à toutes les dimensions du
sport c'est une pratique qui demande
énormément d'efforts ça de développent
toutes les qualités physiques que ce
soit la force la vitesse les
coordination motrice etc on peut parler
aussi de sensations de des scream de soi
c'est à dire que quand on franchit
quelque chose ça nous a fallu du temps
pour nous entraîner pour vraiment
arriver à ce qu'on voulait à faire on
ressort plus fort tu confiant en plus
confiant cela